is this like moral checkpoint does isra
is this like supposed to scare
[Music]
me we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah
subhana brothers and sisters and dear
friends I'm here with zishan we're going
to be reacting to something amazing
that's brother YF basam his name is
basam yuf or basam basam YF basam yuf
okay alhamdulillah we're going to watch
this where he's uh an interview I think
in the UK um I think what's it called
time radio yes inshallah let's see so
this is what happened inshallah and what
what triggered him to say Israel can go
f himself or F themselves okay
interesting condemned Hamas and you
recognize Israel's right to exist as
well what is the use of this kind of
question Oh Lord nothing new nothing
change same old just no no no no
why is this has to be like a checkpoint
does Britain have the right to
exist nice I think so what about the
Palestinian right to exist
uh why is this like moral checkpoint
does Israel is is this like supposed to
scare me
what about the Palestinian right to
exist
yes lots of people believe in the but
not is so Israel want us to acknowledge
his right ex government what the Israeli
government and the people who voted for
them was by the way that like the
society is becoming more and more
radical but like let's say Israel
government like they put us through all
of these moral checkpoints does Israel
have the right to exist does Israel have
right to defend himself but when we ask
them the same question about
Palestinians they have all of these like
winding an that they don't want to exist
they don't even want the right to of
other people to exist it's true we're
all in danger it doesn't make sense
anymore you understand does it make
sense to you this whole idea about like
the moral checkpoint point question that
doesn't like Le to anywhere and then
when we ask the same question about
Palestinians we are phc of like all kind
of things about their terrist they
animals for these horrible inhuman
animals it just it doesn't make sense
yes we could talk about this like all
all of these questions doesn't make it
it just fills the air useless questions
do you condemn Hamas do you condemn is
do you condemn Israel does it does it
matter if you condemn Israel we've been
condemning Israel they're doing whatever
they want these are like haven't you
just like reached a point where you
looking at these questions are very
stupid emotional damage here's the thing
about like Israeli spok benett went on
one day on the on and and he said not
every people in the world have the right
to exist the curse doesn't have a sayate
the people in the B doesn't have the not
everyone in the world who wants a state
gets one uh the Kurds for example don't
have a state they want one the Bas want
a state they don't have
one but when it comes to Israel it's all
about their right Israel have the right
to defend itself Israel had the right to
exist and I heard say like Israel have
the right to
go what do you make out of that cuz like
to me it was actually like very
important we don't it's like it's
actually a stupid question it's like why
does every Western journalist media
Outlet have to start off with why is the
base point do you condemn October 7th do
you condemn Hamas why why why are we
even starting the conversation like this
because they're trying to direct the
conversation to where they want because
they know an ethnic cleansing a genocide
and these terms haven't just been said
by you know Pro Palestine or um you know
people that are biased these These are
terms that have been used by officials
Israeli officials like David Cameron
called it an open Gaza he called it an
open air prison and you've got the even
even though the higher ups I think so G
Gora Island yeah who's the understand
why you need to go there who who's the
former head of Israeli National Security
Council called it a huge concentration
camp Human Rights Watch bit Saleem
Amnesty International called it a system
of apartheid Richard Goldstone a South
African judge called the elements of
crimes against humanity so these are not
necessarily Palestinian individuals that
have used these terms and they know if
the conversation goes towards this it's
going to be very difficult to defend
Israel and to defend a criminal so what
they have to do is they have to package
it in certain way and get people and
draw them to a certain line of
argumentation that you you have to start
by responding to what the person has
said that's why n chsky said whoever
starts the discussion rules the
discussion so it's interesting it has
psychological implications it's
basically saying that it is all um what
what it what choreographed uh yeah Parra
yes basically because what it is in a
nutshell is that the fact that they're
starting it all the time with that
question it's like you're always on the
book back foot and you can see that
these are people who have mastered this
you know even there's this guide books
that were given to these Jour no but Ali
why don't the Palestinians have their
own news Outlet so they can do it what
so when you have been speaking and we've
been speaking of Palestine how has our
social media being Shadow band yeah you
know it it was actually this has
actually been done there's an objective
study that's been done and the
conclusion is Facebook has been you know
it's one of the social medias that has
been negatively um portraying news about
Palestine the censoring has been taking
place so it shows that the power of
freedom of speech if they actually these
individuals who Advocate freedom of
speech if they actually allowed freedom
of speech it works in favor of Muslims
in all Paradigm like if you allowed to
gave us the absolute freedom of speech
to propagate Islam people come to people
will flock into Islam which they are
alhamd C count that allow us to do that
and even when it comes to like talking
about objectively if you allowed us
genuine freedom of speech and imagine
these are sensored and the whole world
has turned against Israel just imagine
if they if we were not unsensored bro
just imagine implication if we not un
sens and that's why the prophet peace be
upon him told us that speech is like and
that is exactly you can see the way they
have organize when to start it what to
say repeat something repeat over and
over again you see all the media Outlets
repeat repeting the same thing over and
over it's like programming programming
it's like if you repeat a lie so many
times people believe it to be true
exactly and you can see that they use
this AR this is actually gobellan
propaganda used at the time of Hitler
really oh wow but here's what's
interesting you mentioned basam YF uh I
was speaking to somebody who's kind of
very senior um I don't want to use his
name but he said that basam yusf has
been an integral part in the Pro
Palestinian course and I know it soundss
obvious but he's actually saying to such
a degree that he's actually you know
swayed he's actually been like uh what
you what do you call it like a you know
when the ball's going one way and it
actually goes the other way okay I get
get you know what I mean like he's been
somebody that they unex he was
unexpected yes and and the thing with
basam yusf is he's been on loads of
discussions you probably see come up on
your feed okay he's being interviewed by
this by that and he's constantly asked
the same question
see it Allan out the last few mons
clearly that they're bombing the north
now people are coming to the South now
as they come to the South they're being
bombed when they come to the South
they're being bombed even the
international court is saying don't you
know bomb Rafa you're getting
International people acknowledging this
and saying you know what it's wrong even
you did a video of PE Morgan saying you
know what this is this is getting
R that's why when he still despite all
of this they are still going on with the
rhetoric I think it's safe to assume
that you can give your middle finger to
these people and say you know what I I
this is ridiculous now and literally
take their pants down because now people
realize even the thick people are
realizing you know what this is getting
a bit ridiculous now like P Morgan where
are the thick
people the prophet Sall alhi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah subhana tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in Jenna our
books will be given and every little
atom weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you donate now guys and
do not delay and share the video for
extra Rewards